Speaker 1: Yesterday, former President Bill
Clinton appeared at a campaign event for Josh
Riley, a Democrat running for the New York
House.
And it's less.
This showing you this clip is less about Josh
Riley.
It's more about Bill Clinton, perfectly summing
up modern era Republicans.
I'll just play the clip and then we'll talk
about it.
Speaker 5: The Republicans are pretty simple,
actually.
They're pretty straightforward.
They say, I want you to be very miserable
and I want you to be very angry and I vote.
I want you to vote for us and we'll make it
worse.
But we'll blame them.
Unidentified: Yeah.
I mean.
Speaker 1: That is exactly what the modern
Republican Party is.
They don't propose policy.
They don't bring any big ideas of any value
or substance.
Let's think through an example.
Think about the economy.
Right now, Republicans are saying the economy
is bad right now.
The economy's bad right now.
That's not true.
The economy is actually pretty solid right
now by all standard economic indicators.
Is inflation high?
Yes, but we're at almost full employment.
GDP growth is back.
Stock market is shaky, but not a disaster.
We have all the data.
So they lie by saying the economy is currently
bad.
They say Democrats are terrible for the economy
and we'll make it better.
Vote for us.
The truth is, historically, Democrats are
better for the economy.
Historically, we have higher job growth when
there's a Democratic president, stock market
performance better.
Under a Democratic president, we have lower
unemployment.
Under a Democratic president, GDP growth is
higher.
Under a Democratic president, inflation is
lower.
Under a Democratic president on average.
Okay.
So then you elect them.
They don't make it any better because they're
worse for the economy.
We know that.
But when it gets worse, they'll say, well,
it's the fault of Democrats.
If they control the Senate and the White House
and the economy doesn't do as well as they
claim it should have done.
They will say, well, even though we had the
White House in the Senate, the economy didn't
do so well because Democrats controlled the
House.
It is spot on.
Spot on.
Analysis from Bill Clinton here.
And they've abandoned policy, as I've told
you many times before.
And it's these cultural issues, these contrived
issues of wokeness and litter boxes.
And in fact, that's exactly what I want to
talk
about next.